let's evaluate each side of each equation, starting with this one up here. Log
base 10 of 100 is 2, and log base 10 of 1000 is 3. So, we have 2 over 3 for
this side. On the right-hand side we have log base 10 of 100 again, or 2, and
then, minus 3 for log base 10 of 1000, this equals negative 1. Unfortunately
for this equation, two thirds is not equal to negative 1, so this is not a true
statement, we need to put a not equals sign here. Let's move over here to this
equation. The left-hand side right now is log base 10 of 100 over 1000. So let's
look at whats inside the parentheses and simplify that. 100 over 1000 is 1 over
10 and 1 over 10 is the same as 10 to the negative 1. Log base 10 of 10 to the
negative 1 is just negative 1. Great. What about the right-hand side? Well this
is the same as what we had over here. And we got negative 1 for that. Sure
enough negative 1 is equal to negative 1. So, this equation is true. Awesome.
Now what about this last one here? Well, once again let's start with what's
inside the parentheses here. We have log base 10 of 100 minus 1000. Which is
the same as log base 10 of negative 900. Hm, I'm not sure what this is so how
about I pull out the calculator and we'll see what this equals. So we have log
base 10 of negative 900, and look at that we get an error. I wonder why that
is? Well actually, we know why. We're trying to take the log of a negative
number, and you learned before that, that is not allowed. This is just not
equal to a real number. On the right-hand side, we have what we had over here,
two thirds. Well, two thirds is a real number, so that means this equation is
not true. This second one, log base 10 of 100 over 1000, is equal to log base
10 of 100, minus log base 10 of 1000. Is the only example of the quotient rule
being used properly of these three equations. This is a great check to show
that the quotient property actually works. And I hope it's also pointed out
some easy ways that you might accidently make a mistake when you're trying to
use it.